I am mauricio cardenas senior fellow and
director of the Latin America initiative
at the Brookings Institution in
Washington DC I'm going to be answering
two questions one how is Latin America
addressing the drug problem and to what
is the current situation of the debate
on legalization of drugs we had a great
debate here at the original Latin
America meeting of the world economic
forum there is a lot of discussion and
debate on what's happening in Latin
America and I think the key word of
today's panel is concerned and as much
as Latin America is opportunity because
this is the decade and the region is
growing very fast it is also true that
the region is facing tremendous threats
from the drug organization come from
organized crime and especially true in
Central America so the debate is how to
best tackle the problem of drugs and the
keyword main lesson of this conversation
is that this cannot be the unilateral
action of a neighborhood like a favela
in rio de janeiro or a city or state or
a national government this requires
international coordination because the
balloon effect is pretty much a
pervasive in this problem you suppress
the problem in one part and it exposed
in another point so this requires a
international coordination
l on the topic of how to reach a
solution much of the emphasis now is on
rebalancing counter-narcotics policies
that have been too much filtered in the
election of efforts to reduce apply and
legal action in terms of reducing
consumption this is one important
message and trading consumption less is
a criminal activity and more as a public
health problem on the issue of
legalization there was a big debate
arguments in favor and against pull it
from the grassroots organizations and
from the perspectives that look at this
at the super national level and the
point is that unless voters move in a
direction it's going to be very hard for
political leaders to take action there
is a lot of expectation on what's going
to happen in the next two years in the
United States as some states both play
besides and referendums or propositions
on the issue of legalizing the
consumption of marijuana that could be a
trigger to a broader discussion with
ramifications into Latin America but
what looks at this point is that it's
very unlikely that the debate will be
initiated from Latin America on the
issue of legalization so though eyes are
now put on the United States coders and
in particular on the voters of the state
of California